a combination of a TV star and TV
character viewers welcomed Richard
Harrison into their homes over several
hundred episodes his presence from the
pawn shop and Pawn Stars will be missed
and he's just as compelling of a guy
after he passed on Richard Harrison died
on June 25th 2018 at the age of 77 his
son Pawn Stars Rick Harrison confirmed
his father's passing via Instagram
underneath a stylish shot of the old man
the younger Harrison wrote in part
Richard Benjamin the old man Harrison
passed away this morning surrounded by
those he loved he will be tremendously
missed by our family the team at gold
and silver pond and his many fans the
world over there's a lot of memories
here and most of those memories are with
my father
later that day rick released another
photo of the old man this time as a
young man to instagram revealing in his
caption that the elder harrison had
quote lost his long battle with
parkinson's this morning very few people
outside of Harrison's inner circle knew
that he was sick so his death was a
surprise to most as was the cause a
devastating progressive neurological
condition shortly after the old man died
Pawn Stars Austin Chumlee Russell told
TMZ we had kind of been preparing for it
for a while now and I spent quite a bit
of time at his house this past week just
knowing that it could be coming soon and
I wanted to make sure I had plenty of
time and memories left with him while he
was still here it was awesome I'll go
with you
no you won't dum-dum I'll go by myself
the average viewer probably had no idea
that Harrison served in a variety of
roles in the US Navy for more than 20
years as rick recalled in his 2011 book
licensed upon the old man stole a car
when he was 17 and a north carolina
judge gave him a choice enlist or go to
jail
enlist he did and after training he
shipped out for tours on two different
destroyers over the following years he
won promotions all the way up to first
class petty officer and retired from the
Navy in 1979 Harrison told Navy Times
out of twenty years I was deployed about
ten the only reason I got out was that I
had three teenage boys and the wife
couldn't handle them Harrison died a
wealthy man at the age of 77 he set up a
will naming his wife and three son
as his heirs and beneficiaries his
trusted Pawn Stars partner Rick was
named the executor but according to
legal papers published by the blast
Harrison filed an update in 2017 that he
specified to make sure his son
Christopher didn't get a dime
the old man wrote in the document I
would like to express my love and
affection for Christopher Keith Harrison
however for purposes of this will I have
intentionally and with full knowledge
failed to provide for him and his issue
he gave no reason for the financial
slight so what's next for Pawn Stars
just two days after Harrison's death the
History Channel aired a treasure
remembered a special tribute episode
consisting of Harrison's most memorable
moments not long after the show went
into production for its 16th season Rick
Corey and Chumlee all returned and no
new hires were brought in to replace the
old man there has been one major change
for Pawn Stars however when it returned
after a long hiatus in January 2019 the
shows episodes doubled in length
expanding from a half-hour running time
to a full hour check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]